well arthel carlos family is forced to
tighten their
belts under cove lockdowns this year
while they're finding their holly
holiday gift list doesn't fit into their
budgets this year
charities that collect and distribute
donations say they have received
more requests for help now than ever
jayla whitfield
has more boxes that are usually
filled with donated toys are sitting
empty
the need is 10 times what it was last
year i mean it's unreal
sherry carnegie with the atlanta toys
for tots
says the coronavirus has affected them
in every area
from the volunteers from the the number
of events that we have
from the netherlands toys that have been
donated toys for tots has 816 campaigns
across the country
and the atlanta campaign is the largest
last year we distributed
almost 850 000 toys and this year
our campaign has distributed about 225
000 toys
so far carnegie says volunteers are down
too to get the toys in is one thing but
then we still have to sort them and we
still have to bag them we still have to
get them out the door
sergeant dominique jones is a marine who
helps during toy donation events
but those are down two-thirds from last
year
for the most part we've seen a decline
and a lot of
giving from different organizations
local organizations
like lift up atlanta are struggling too
some families have never asked for
assistance and
and they are actually asking for
donations
garner says they're going to do their
best to help every
child that they can you don't want
one child to go without and other kids
have
but if organizations don't receive more
toy donations
some kids may be out of luck
unfortunately unless we get the
donations in there will be some children
who go without christmas this year the
pandemic has forced toys for tots to get
creative
you can now buy toy online and get it
sent directly to the distribution site
of your choice in atlanta jayla
woodfield fox news
jayla very important story thank you